what do you do if little man is your
relative
so i got a great question for one of my
youtube viewers love you guys
samir who wrote in to say amazing videos
thanks evan
i have a question for you what if the
little man is your relative in my life i
have many little men but these little
men
are my relatives and i love them so much
what should i do
so samir you know i'm going to be honest
with you this question
caused me a lot of uh
stress usually when i get a question i
i can get in front of the camera and i
just start answering at this point i had
to kind of walk around and and think
about it for a while
for those of you watching a little man
the little man is the person in your
life who tells you you can't make it it
tells you
that you're not good enough who tells
you to give up on your dream it tells
you to do something else
and and you can't listen to the little
man you know you got to do your own
thing and we all have these little men
in our lives who hold us back from doing
the things that we want to do
what are you doing as a family member
i'm kind of hesitant to jump on
that kind of personal advice i don't
want the guilt
i don't want the guilt maybe i'll just
share my story
i think first of all you have to
determine who the who family is
uh if it's your your spouse or not i
think the person who you
spend the rest of your life with should
be somebody who
who believes in what you're doing who
supports you even if
he or she doesn't understand what you're
doing
uh we should be supportive of the people
who who we're married to
right so hopefully the little man is not
the person who you're
you're seeing girlfriend boyfriend
husband wife
what do you do with the other members in
your family
you know there's one person in my life
i'm fortunate that
my close family are all very supportive
of what i do my parents my siblings
you know my mom schedules in her
calendar every day i have a radio show
and she listens in
and uh you know that's great to have
that kind of support and a lot of people
don't necessarily have that support
growing up
there is one person in kind of my
extended family who who
is just negative and as i grew up caused
tons of grief not only for me but for
everybody in the family and so i've had
to write
this person off from my life and if
there's family functions
you know i avoid them if i know that
this person's gonna be there
and it causes a little bit of of
scheduling
issues i guess but but i'm so much
happier right like i don't need more
negativity in my life
running a business is hard enough i
don't need more frustrations
and in general i eliminate
people from my life who who are the
little man i
limit the people who who are just
negative you know they're people who are
just
just just negative they suck your time
they suck your energy
they make you you know you leave a
conversation with them feeling bad about
yourself
i don't want to be surrounded by those
people you know
friends are easier or friends are easier
to get rid of i guess than than family
members
um but there is one person in my life
i've had to in my family
extended family we've had to do that
with you know right or wrong decision
i'm a happier person as a result of it i
have less negativity in my life because
of it so i'm i'm
comfortable with that decision you know
i don't want to tell you
i don't know who the little man is in
your life i don't want to tell you don't
talk to your parents because
they're the little man in your life this
is the personal choice you have to make
for yourself but what i
what i believe in and maybe this helps
is that you have to live your own life
you're living your life for you you
can't live somebody else's dream
you can't live somebody else's life you
know if your parents want you to be a
doctor
and you want to be an entrepreneur my
view is you got to do your thing
like you're never going to be happy
living somebody else's life it's just
it's somebody else's dream it's not your
dream you have to do what excites you
what gets you excited
right and there's a point as we grow up
where you know we're trying to please
our parents all the time
and you know through school then there's
a point where you break off and you
decide
like i'm ready to become my own person
that may mean
going against what your family wants you
to do
uh you know i think of i think of it's
harder in some cultures i think of
the founder of of sony akio
his family had been in the same business
for multiple generations and they just
expected him to take over
and he didn't want to do that he's like
i i don't like this business i don't
want to be in this family business it's
not for me i want to do my own thing i
want to start my own company
and they you know didn't agree and put
huge pressure on him and that was more
you know the culture and i guess
japanese culture at the time and
and he still had the courage to go and
do his own thing and he built sony built
one of the
biggest brands in the world and if he
had just done
you know his family business he wouldn't
be happy he wouldn't be successful
and he'd always be thinking like what if
i went out and did
my own thing how much happier how much
more successful would i be
you got to follow your heart you know
you got to do
what you believe is the best thing for
you even if that means
upsetting people in your family who
think
a different path is better for you how
you maintain the relationship if you
choose to maintain the relationship or
not if there's a break if it's
not talking about your business i don't
know like i'm not the expert on that
but um i sincerely hope that you don't
let
other people's dreams and other people's
visions for what
they think you should do become your
reality
and instead i want you to focus on what
you feel in your heart is the right
thing to do
do that first focus on that big thing
first
and then line everything up afterwards
that's the most important decision and
then how everything else follows
you have to figure it out i don't know
if that helps
maybe not the most concrete video i've
ever put together and it did cause me a
lot of stress and thinking about it
but um those are my thoughts so believe
for those who watching like the video
thumbs up below let me know what you
think leave a comment your comments i
love your comments they make me they're
the fuel for me every day so please
comment below
you have a question put in the comments
too and uh subscribe to the channel by
clicking on my face
if you want to see more videos like this
thank you so much for watching and i'll
see you soon
you